A funny thing sometimes happens
when you rehang stitches.
Anytime you rehang a cast on edge,
you end up with one less stitch.
Have you ever noticed that?
I'm knitting an ear flap for a hat.
I've worked in open cast
on with scrap and ravel.
Let's say I cast on 20 stitches.
I knit my triangle and the ties.
Now when it's time to rehang the flap on
the needle bed to join that flap to the
hat body, I can only find
19 stitches to pick up.
Why is that?
In this drawing, I've cast on
and knit a bit over six needles.
Six columns of stitches, right?
When I rotate the knitting to pick up a
hem or hang my triangle flaps, it looks
like there are only five
full stitches to pick up.
It's just the nature of knitting.
We have a half stitch on each end.
What to do?
Well, it depends on what you're knitting.
For a hem.
This probably isn't going to matter.
But you could pick up one of those
half stitches to keep your stitch count
accurate.
You could use the tail of yarn that's
close by and eWrap an extra stitch.
The solution is really up to you, but this
is just something to be aware of and keep
in mind to keep your stitch counts
accurate when you're picking up stitches.